[Music]
imagine that one day you're summoned
before a government panel even though
you haven't committed any crime or been
formally charged with one you are
repeatedly questioned about your
political views accused of disloyalty
and asked to incriminate your friends
and associates if you don't cooperate
you risk jail or losing your job this is
exactly what happened in the United
States in the 1950s as part of a
campaign to expose suspected communists
named after its most notorious
practitioner the phenomenon known as
McCarthyism destroyed thousands of lives
and careers for over a decade American
political leaders trampled democratic
freedoms in the name of protecting them
during the 1930s and 1940s there had
been an active but small Communist Party
in the United States its record was
mixed while it played crucial roles in
wider progressive struggles for labor
and civil rights it also supported the
Soviet Union from the start the American
Communist Party faced attacks from
conservatives and business leaders as
well as from liberals who criticized its
ties to the oppressive Soviet regime
during World War two when the USA and
USSR were allied against Hitler some
American communists actually spied for
the Russians when the Cold War escalated
and this espionage became known domestic
communism came to be seen as a threat to
national security but the attempt to
eliminate that threat soon turned into
the longest lasting and most widespread
episode of political repression in
American history spurred on by a network
of bureaucrats politicians journalists
and businessmen the campaign wildly
exaggerated the danger of communist
subversion the people behind it harassed
anyone suspected of holding
left-of-center political views or
associating with those who did
if you hung Modern Art on your walls had
a multiracial social circle or signed
petitions against nuclear weapons you
might just have been a communist
starting in the late 1940s FBI director
J Edgar Hoover used the resources of his
agency to hunt down such supposed
communists and eliminate them from any
position of influence with an American
Society
and the narrow criteria that Hoover and
his allies used to screen federal
employees spread to the rest of the
country soon Hollywood studios
universities car manufacturers and
thousands of other public and private
employers were imposing the same
political tests on the men and women who
worked for them
meanwhile Congress conducted its own
witch-hunt subpoenaing hundreds of
people to testify before investigative
bodies like the house on American
Activities Committee if they refuse to
cooperate they could be jailed for
contempt or more commonly fired and
blacklisted ambitious politicians like
Richard Nixon and Joseph McCarthy used
such hearings as a partisan weapon
accusing Democrats of being soft on
communism and deliberately losing China
to the communist bloc McCarthy a
Republican senator from Wisconsin became
notorious by flaunting ever-changing
lists of alleged communists within the
State Department
egged on by other politicians he
continued to make outrageous accusations
while distorting or fabricating evidence
many citizens reviled McCarthy while
others praised him and when the Korean
War broke out
McCarthy seemed vindicated
once he became chair of the Senate's
permanent Subcommittee on investigations
in 1953 McCarthy's recklessness
increased it was his investigation of
the army that finally turned public
opinion against him and diminished his
power
McCarthy's colleagues in the Senate
censured him and he died less than three
years later probably from alcoholism
McCarthyism ended as well it had ruined
hundreds if not thousands of lives and
drastically narrowed the American
political spectrum its damage to
democratic institutions would be
long-lasting
in all likelihood there were both
Democrats and Republicans who knew that
the anti-communist purges were deeply
unjust but feared that directly opposing
them would hurt their careers
even the Supreme Court failed to stop
the witch-hunt condoning serious
violations of constitutional rights in
the name of national security was
domestic communism an actual threat to
the American government perhaps though a
small one but the reaction to it was so
extreme that it caused far more damage
than the threat itself and if new
demagogues appeared in uncertain times
to attack unpopular minorities in the
name of patriotism could it all happen
again
you
[Music]